entre communautés serbe et albanaise se
poursuivre cette affaire de vache folle
ou plutôt présentant tous des symptômes
et découvertes dans un abattoir du
morbihan sans certificat vétérinaire
les tentatives de la fraude michel 6
ce spéléologue sous terre depuis
soixante jours sans repères du temps
remontera demain à la surface un pari
déjà réussi pour cet aventurier au
service de la science cinéma avec la
sortie de la plage marquant le retour à
l'écran de leonardo dicaprio une actrice
française joue à ses côtés dans ce film
de danny boyle une parabole sur la quête
des plaisirs des sensations et du
paradis virginie ledoyen et la victime
ce journal au kosovo dans la rue la
région de mitrovica les incidents se
multiplient ces derniers jours et
l'armée française se trouve confronté à
cette improbable mission tenter de
maintenir la paix dans cette zone où les
tensions entre les deux communautés
allume épisodiquement des flambées de
violence ce matin deux soldats français
ont été blessés
ces dernières heures un calme apparent
semblait se maintenir dans la partie
nord de la ville alain de chalvron
ce ne sont plus de simples violences
ethniques ou des situations de forte
tension mais bien des scènes de guerre
qu'a connue mitrovic à en fin de matinée
pendant deux heures les tirs ont été
nourries tirs d'armes légères mais aussi
de gros calibre entre serbes et albanais
mais surtout contre la kfor les forces
de l'otan deux soldats français ont été
blessés grièvement
mais il serait hors de danger faire
contre ce tout ce qu'on veut plus que
notre ici aujourd'hui ce n'était plus
une question d'affrontement deux
communautés
c'était bien de hull de libérer contre
le fort les français et les autres
contingents de la kfor ont pris position
dans les zones d'où partaient les tirs à
proximité de la rivière ibar qui sépare
les quartiers serbes et albanais 6
francs tireurs albanais ont été
neutralisés apparemment ceux qui
visaient les français l'un a été tué et
cinq autres blessés mais des francs
tireurs
il y en avait bien sûr du côté serbe
si les militaires de l'otan semblent
avoir été les premiers visés les civils
n'ont pas été épargnés ici un serbe
blessé par un franc tireur
quant aux résidents albanais des
quartiers nord les quartiers serbe
ils ont repris le chemin de l'exil vers
le sud de la ville à travers la rivière
ibar en grande bretagne après le
détournement du boeing afghan il ya tout
juste une semaine seulement 17 des 164
passagers souhaitent rentrer dans leur
pays une centaine d'ex otages ont été
transférés hier soir vers un centre
d'immigration leur destination finale
est toujours incertaine et la question
du droit d'asile est éminemment complexe
maryse burgot
ces afghans que la presse britannique ne
peut pas approcher furent d'abord des
otages
puis à partir de vendredi après la fin
heureuse du détournement d'avion on
s'interrogera sur leur éventuelle
complicité avec les preneurs d'otages
ce soir ceci n'est pas prouvée mais on
constate que seulement 17 des 164
passagers souhaitent rentrer chez eux
tous les autres demandent l'asile
politique
ils veulent vivre en grande bretagne ils
sont donc rassemblés dans ce service
d'immigration à l'ouest de londres
et il pose un sérieux dilemme nos
ministres de l'intérieur britannique
ce sont les mots qu'il a employés ce
soir car comment accepter de donner
l'asile politique à ces genres en danger
dans leur pays sans encourager la
manière dont ils sont arrivés c'est à
dire à l'occasion d'un détournement
d'avion la presse populaire britannique
elle a choisi son camp même l'avion ne
repartira plus jamais regrette ton à la
une du sun
cette afghane a fait le régime des
talibans réfugiés politiques
elle s'émeut de cette offensive dans les
tabloïds contre l'arrivée de nouveaux
étrangers
ces gens sont en danger dans leur propre
pays comme ce fut le cas pour moi il
doit pouvoir rester ici il faut que les
anglais comprennent cela sur une base
militaire à l'ouest de londres un avion
est prêt pour rapatrier les ex otages
qui le souhaitent
mais plus le temps passe moins ils sont
nombreux la grande bretagne a la
réputation d'être une terre d'accueil
pour les étrangers mais ici comme en
france ou ailleurs en europe cette
tradition est sérieusement remise en
question
la récente affaire du détournement
d'avion ne faisant qu exacerber les
sentiments de xénophobie d'une certaine
partie de la population
en france de nouvelles précisions et de
nouveaux développements après la
découverte cette semaine dans un
abattoir d'un animal présentant des
signes de la maladie de la vache folle
et sans certificats stipulant l'état de
santé suspect une affaire préoccupante
qui laisse à penser que les tentatives
de fraude demeure aujourd'hui les
services vétérinaires qui ont examiné
cet animal racontent reportage olivier
cieux
les dirigeants de la société galets
ont-ils tout dit et surtout tout dit aux
services vétérinaires ce matin son
directeur semblait affirmé que c'est
l'entreprise elle-même qui avait pris
l'initiative de prévenir les services
vétérinaires
après la découverte d'une vache suspecte
dans l'abattoir c'est bien vous qui
avait prévenu les services vétérinaires
nous qui les avons donc isoler l'animal
est prévu derrière parce que selon le
rapport de gendarmerie on peut
comprendre que c'était à la suite d'une
inspection que cette découverte a été
faite dans la lah l'animal a été isolé
par nous-mêmes dell mardi soir or les
services vétérinaires ne font pas
exactement entendre le même son de
cloche je suis monté mois avec la carte
sanitaire dans le bureau du directeur
lucide et qu'il avait un animal malade
en boucherie ce qui ne vous avais pas
dit ce qui nous avait pas dit non les
services vétérinaires affirme également
que cette même entreprise actuellement
en redressement judiciaire faisait
l'objet d'une vigilance particulière à
la suite de plusieurs incidents récents
le vétérinaire inspecteur que j'ai
rappelé ce matin me confirmer
qu'effectivement il ya eu effectivement
des antécédents je vais pas la première
fois ce n'est pas la première fois non
les types d'antécédents elle le fait que
des animaux pouvaient arriver sans sans
document d'information qui fait déjà
donc été consignés par nos services
oui peut-être or le certificat
vétérinaire est obligatoire pour les
animaux malades face aux incertitudes de
le sbc pour l'administration un premier
filtre bien nous avions joué notre rôle
qui le deuxième filtre seca l'abattoir
il y à une inspection permanente fait
par des techniciens
il évite à une heure et à l'abattoir
nous devons faire une inspection qu'on
appelle avant abattage l'animal et une
inspection après l'abattage troisième
filtre l'incinération systématique des
morceaux à risque comme la cervelle
certains peuvent-ils être tentés de
passer à travers les mailles du filet
avec des animaux suspects c'est ce que
l'enquêté en cours devra déterminer en
commençant par établir si en
l'occurrence il s'agissait oui ou non
d'une vache folle au-delà des
conséquences purement écologique de la
marée noire sur la côte atlantique les
professionnels du tourisme comme les
ostréiculteurs sont extrêmement inquiets
la saison s'annonce catastrophique et
les ventes du
tron chuté même si marennes d'oléron
l'île de ré n'ont pas été touchés par la
marée noire christophe devals embrasse
alain darrigrand gerra chotard est
ostréiculteur à brouage dans le bassin
de marennes oléron après l'ouragan
il est maintenant victimes de la marée
noire de l'erika ou plutôt d'une sorte
de psychose de méfiance qu'elle
déclenche chez les consommateurs mois de
janvier on a fait à peu près 40 à 50% le
tonnage andreu et le mois de février
annonce malheureusement il s'annonce
pareil et là on comprend pas on comprend
pas pourquoi le consommateur nous
boycott alors que le les nappes de
pétrole éventuellement sur la plusieurs
centaines de kilomètres de nos clercs on
a été assimilée à la marée noire
médiatique qui a eu et il ya eu un doute
sur les lieux que nous habitons et sur
les produits que nous vendons et vous
l'avez vu vous même il n'en est rien
marée noire médiatique fictive le fioul
de l'erika n'a effectivement jamais
touché le bassin de marennes oléron
quelques informations approximatives et
les consommateurs ont cru voir la
pollution sur toute la côte atlantique
idem pour les touristes conséquence dans
ce camping de l'île de ré deux fois
moins de réservations que d'habitude
parce qu'il se passe ce qu'ils ont pas
arrêté d'entendre la marée noire de la
bretagne à l'île de ré à l'île de ré
alors que l'île de ré n'est pas touché
mais comme on entend toujours l'île de
ré les devrait toucher résultats à la
flotte-en-ré les jambes ou de l'office
du tourisme 50 % de demandes
d'informations en moins par rapport à
l'an dernier
les gens imaginent et beaucoup de choses
et beaucoup de choses qui ont été tissés
certain mais on imaginer beaucoup choses
et à partir de là sont complètement
fabulé ils ont cru voir un télévison la
page et la flore de l'île de ré ce
mazout chose qui n'est pas vrai il n'ya
pas du tout de pollution sur la plage
pas de galettes de mazout
on en a eu bien sûr un petit peu au
départ 15 jours après le l'erika à la
pointe de l'île ça a été enlevé à deux
jours
et pourtant les touristes boudent cette
plage il est encore trop tôt pour
évaluer l'impact de cette marée noire
virtuel mais les dommages économiques
seront eux bien réels
après la tempête de cette fin d'année
qui a déraciné des milliers d'arbres le
premier convoi ferroviaire transportant
quelques 10000 mètres cubes de bois
quitter cette gare au nord de limoges à
destination d'une scierie industrielle
ce qu'on voit le premier du genre est né
du partenariat entre la sncf et la
filière bois du limousin
alors que l'éducation nationale faisait
connaître cette semaine les premiers
dispositifs de la carte scolaire et que
la mobilisation d'enseignants et de
parents d'élèves ne faiblit pas pour
obtenir davantage de postes pour une
école de qualité
nous nous sommes intéressés à cet
exemple dans l'essonne où se côtoient
une grande école et une banlieue
défavorisée chaque jour depuis cinq ans
les étudiantes de supélec se relaient
pour apporter un soutien scolaire ou
collégiens désunissent et ça marche au
delà de toute espérance
une expérience qui pourrait à terme se
généraliser et la nuque
frédéric de la rue dans deux trois ans
plus tard ils sauront ingénieur
directeur de banque ou chefs
d'entreprise étudiants à supélec l'une
des plus grandes écoles d'ingénieurs en
france
leur avenir est tracé leur intégration
dans la vie garanti pourtant chaque soir
il quitte l'univers protégé du campus
direction les ulis ces quartiers hlm ses
enfants à l'avenir plus incertain entre
leurs cours et leurs devoirs les supélec
comme on les appelle ici viennent offrir
un peu de leur temps et de leur savoir
aux enfants de la banlieue c'est
l'entrée de scolaires mises en place
avec la municipalité
avec avec le cod j'avais l'impression
que c'est parti ce site et ses banlieues
parisiennes avait un lac salé bon que
sous les habits et je trouvais que
c'était dommage de pas leur rendre un
peu de ce que j'avais pu avoir
en même temps ça correspondait à une sur
la société que j'avais où tout le monde
avait un accès égal à certains services
publics en particulier et les collégiens
sont demandeurs certains viennent tous
les soirs après les fours à l'entr'aide
faire leurs devoirs
pendant deux heures ils trouvent ici
l'aide et l'écouté qui n'ont pas
forcément chez eux travaillent et
l'entraînent nous porte ses fruits
mac et c est bien le fils est 6e elle
est aujourd'hui en trois heures
j'avais des difficultés partout puis
depuis cette année-là mais l'année
dernière et à l'argent c'est grâce à
tout le monde sauf les lettres
s'il entrait profite aux collégiens la
réciproque est vraie les supélec
ils trouvent aussi leur compte retour en
fait puisque quand quelqu'un vient vous
demander où quand quelqu'un une bonne
note
quelque part ça il ya une sorte de jeu
fierté d'avoir réussi avec une oie ou
leur histoire leur expression on pourra
presque enfantine assurait qu'on allait
les expressions des des enfants des ulis
et à guémar en cdi sont un peu perdus
est ce que tu as appris ça bah ouais ça
vous il y sera d'accord aujourd'hui ce
sont les mots de la banlieue qui font
leur entrée à supélec un jeu peut-être
ce seront ses enfants la bataille pour
la mairie de paris personne n'est
vraiment candidats en tout cas
officiellement déclaré mais quelques
poids lourds de la politique sans
plébiscitée dans les sondages parus
notamment cette fin de semaine l'opinion
publique verrait bien un duel philippe
séguin jack lang eux ne voient ou le
disent ne rien voir tant que les
militants ne se seront pas prononcés
drôle de jeu de pronostics de silence et
de petites phrases lörrach kim gilbert
usant le problème avec les parisiens
c'est qu'il voudrait le maire de blois
où l'ancien maire d'epinal et que jack
lang comme philippe séguin se font
désirer en attendant à référendum et
pourquoi pas un plébiscite de leurs
militants respectifs dans les sondages
les deux jokers rafle la mise y compris
dans leur propre formation politique à
gauche jack lang devance bertrand
delanoë déjà candidat à droite philippe
séguin part favori face à jean tiberi ou
françoise de panafieu déjà dans la
course
le duel langue séguin lui promet d'être
serrée 6 points tout au plus c'est par
les deux hommes en faveur du député des
vosges déjà à l'affût pas encore en
embuscade
jack lang est en campagne comme ici dans
le 19e arrondissement
même s'il feint l'amusement lorsqu'on
lui parle de combat des titans
qu'il faut quand même ne pas se prendre
trop au sérieux garder la mesure des
choses
le combat des titans ce n'est pas une
expression devoir perdre aide je ne sais
pas qui combattra qui si le cas de la
noé se pose à jack lang le problème pour
philippe séguin s'appelle jean tiberi
l'ancien président du rpr ne veut pas
d'un bras de fer avec le maire sortant
il attend donc le feu vert de michèle
alliot marie
si elle me dit un jour que pour gagner
paris serait souhaitable que je sois
candidat eh bien je lui donne à entendre
que dans ce cas j'accepterai maintenant
si elle ne demandait rien c'est pas moi
qui ai eu l accord est dans son bureau
et déjà les plus proches de jacques
chirac sont résolus à une candidature
séguin pourvu qu'on sorte de la crise si
c'est philippe séguin qui est le
meilleur candidat alors soutenons
philippe séguin et je serai au premier
rang des gens qui le soutiennent
le bureau du maire de paris est
aujourd'hui l'un des plus convoités même
si les favoris avance à pas feutrés le
combat des titans pourrait se jouer avec
jean tiberi qui n'est pas décidé à
renoncer
l'actualité internationale le président
russe pas rater mais par intérim
vladimir poutine sait mieux que personne
utiliser les médias
après s'être fait finement judokas
aujourd'hui il a laissé les télévisions
russes le suivra ce pli candidats
déclarés aux présidentielles et
apparemment sans concurrence vladimir
poutine a su profiter du conflit en
tchétchénie pour s'installer en chef
d'état mais à quel prix sur le terrain
les témoignages faisant état de torture
sont de plus en plus nombreuses les
témoins les associations qui défendent
les droits de l'homme multiplie les
mises en garde à grossemy comme ailleurs
les troupes russes semblent pratiquée
couramment les exactions contre les
civils
nos envoyés spéciaux dorothée olliéric
et didier d'armes à la frontière avec
l'ingouchie ont pu recueillir ces récits
de violence
la femme pleure elle raconte ce qu'elle
vient de voir en chine
je voudrais vous amener jusqu'à ce
village pour que vous puissiez voir de
vos propres sociaux les cadavres qu'est
ce qui s'est passé les soldats russes
sortent investiguer des caves et les
fusils elle jure que son récit est la
stricte vérité
ceux qui attendent des nouvelles de
leurs proches toujours en tchétchénie
sont effondrées depuis plusieurs
semaines les témoignages sur des
exactions commises par les troupes
fédérales se multiplient ces femmes ont
investi le poste frontière pour
protester contre ces crimes
quelques mères quelques banderoles pour
un cri silencieux jetée aux yeux du
monde
on ne fait pas la différence entre
russes et tchétchènes
ce qu'on veut ce la peur dans cette
ferme vivent plusieurs dizaines de
familles tchétchènes les enfants
arrachés à la guerre tente de
réapprendre à vivre loin du fracas des
obus pourquoi ils s'en vas tu as peur
des soldats russes
oui pourquoi les gens allaient table où
ils vivent désormais les gamins ont
retrouvé un peu de sécurité
mais les grands ne leur cache pas les
terribles récit de massacre quant à
nouveaux réfugiés arrivent à la ferme
drame toujours son histoire aux anciens
chez nous les russes ont arrêté les
adolescents et on les a cherché pendant
douze jours
on a retrouvé leurs cadavres douze jours
après ils avaient les dents arrachées et
les mains liées il est violent et après
tu allais jamais ta moussa viennent de
grozny elle a pu facilement quitter la
capitale tchétchène
mais pour les hommes jeunes il faut
passer par des candidats
illustration ou les russes font le tri
entre combattants et civils tchétchènes
dans les camps de filtration et
torturent les gens avec de l'électricité
on en a vu revenir après il était
handicapé certains même perdu l'usagé de
leurs jambes et de leurs bras parfois il
faut aussi des échanges pendant un
tchétchène torturé contre des soldats
russes prisonniers ils rêvent de quitter
cet été à l'exil
mais les anciens le redisent prêts de
l'afrique et de leur côté les autorités
russes dénonce la violence et la cruauté
des indépendantistes tchétchènes
notamment contre les prisonniers russes
la situation en irlande du nord après la
décision de la grande-bretagne de
suspendre les institutions de belfast
faute d'un désarmement suffisant de
l'ira aujourd'hui david trimble chef du
principal parti protestant et premier
ministre de ce gouvernement suspendu
mais au défi les républicains de faire
la preuve de leur attachement à la paix
le temps est venu pour eux de se décider
une fois pour toutes pendant longtemps
ils n'ont pas choisi entre la
négociation politique et le terrorisme
aujourd'hui ce n'est plus possible ah
non dit david trimble
j'en viens maintenant à cette
catastrophe écologique cette pollution
majeure qui tous les pays de l'est
désormais provenant de roumanie ces
concentrations de cyanure extrêmement
toxique se sont déversés dans les eaux
du danube des tonnes de poissons morts
flottaient sur le fleuve cet après midi
romuald venant
depuis ce matin c'est à la fourche que
les pêcheurs du danube capture les
poissons des milliers d'animaux
agonisant empoisonné au cyanure
nous sommes à star estime qu'à peine une
petite commune à 50 kilomètres au nord
de belgrade
toute la journée avec les moyens du bord
les habitants n'ont pas arrêté leur
sinistre besogne
le cyanure un poison extrêmement violent
aval est inhalée ou absorbée par simple
contact avec la peau le produit mortel
ici les gens ont arrêté d'acheter notre
pêche depuis la fin janvier
je sais vraiment plus ce qu'il faut
faire ce matin des experts de l'institut
de biologie de belgrade ont été dépêchés
pour réaliser les premiers prélèvements
afin de connaître la gravité de la
pollution mais hier un peu plus en amont
la concentration en cyanure atteignait 2
milligrammes par litre d'eau alors que
le maximum autorisé de 0,1 mg par litre
20 fois moins
une pollution dont l'origine se situe à
plusieurs centaines de kilomètres de là
en roumanie près de baia mare et dans
une mine d'or ou le cyanure utilisé pour
nettoyer le minerai s'est déversée
contaminant l'eau de la rivière tisza
jusqu'en serbie demain la pollution
devrait atteindre belgrade avant de
continuer sa route vers la mer noire
cette aventure hors du temps un pari
presque gagnée pour le spéléologue
michel siffre qui restait plus de deux
mois sous terre sans notion ni repère
des jours qui s'écoulait michel siffre
devrait remonter à la surface demain le
but de son expérience et d'étudier
l'action du vieillissement sur le rythme
biologique
voici dans quel état d'esprit cet homme
de 61 ans s'apprête à fêter cette
nouvelle victoire sur lui-même vernis
gallienne karine comme a dit julie 12h30
il est temps qu'ils mangent un petit peu
quelque part à 900 mètres sous la terre
michel siffre se remet désormais à
l'heure du laboratoire pendant 69 jours
il est resté solitaire hors du temps je
sais plus ce que j'ai fait hier par
exemple dans ce monde sans aucun repère
on est on est perdu j'étais perdu et le
temps j'ai été prisonnier pour dire
prisonnier du temps subi utile de dire
ça mais le temps n'a plus aucun sens
pour moi
cent jours ni nuit sans variation de
température c'est dans une des galeries
de la grotte de clamouse que michel
siffre et aller se terrer pendant plus
de deux mois il a mangé et dormi à son
rythme toujours épiée par le laboratoire
continuellement soumis à des tests et à
des prélèvements
chaque fois que je fais une urine jeu la
collecte d'argent ne dans une éprouvette
je me sur le volume ensuite je collecte
ça dans des bidons en plastique que je
mets au congélateur à -24 camp avec les
échantillons de salive tout ça c'est pas
très amusant ça permet de connaître le
comportement de et le comparer tête à
des gens qui partiront dans l'espace les
navettes spatiales des voyages lointains
vers mars par exemple où les gens
n'auront pris du tout à vivre
synchronisée par le rythme veille
sommeil des commandos militaires par
exemple peut être amené à travailler
dans des conditions particulières sur
ses pas pour le commun des mortels en
1962 michel siffre était remonté épuisé
du gouffre du scar à son après deux mois
d'isolement
il pensait ne jamais recommencer car je
tremble que ce qui se passe à deux
reprises pourtant il est reparti hors du
temps 72 et en 99 et c'est tout
l'intérêt de cette dernière expérience
d'isolement comparer aux 2 premières
elle permettra de connaître l'évolution
et le vieillissement des cycles naturels
d'une vie c'est de mal à saint valentin
pour nous l'opportunité de vous raconter
cette histoire simple et exemplaire où
l'amour apparaît sur le tard et sert à
proprement parler de véritable remède
un homme et une femme qui n'avait plus
beaucoup de raisons de croire en
l'avenir
reportage en belgique ce film et elle
jean-marie lequertier quand georges
était une partie c'est le bonheur
avec jean louis c'est comme s'il va
découvrir le monde après une longue
absence
pourtant ils ont vécu des choses
aventure rencontré il ya deux ans l'un
et l'autre ont été mariés ont des
enfants mais de cette vie d'alors il ne
leur reste rien pas un meuble pas une
photo presque pas de souvenirs
alors aujourd'hui georgette et
jean-louis se concentrent sur leur
histoire qu'ils ne se lasse pas de
raconter tout a commencé à la cafétéria
la place était prise
les autres étaient occupés je fais
cannelle du mot h avatar biava comme une
place à lons intéressé que on va fait on
a fait connaissance et tout de suite
vous n'êtes plus le coup de foudre
tout a commencé ici donc à la cafétéria
de l'hôpital psychiatrique de lierneux
en belgique
georgette ne revient plus que pour les
répétitions de la chorale mais il est
passé presque dix ans à se faire soigner
jean-louis aussi revient de très loin
même s'il n'a passé qu'un an et demi
dans l'institution au milieu des autres
patients
on vient s'en sortent presqu'aucun ils
le savent bien mais leur rencontre leur
a offert une chance inespérée chacun est
devenue la béquille de l'autre et
ensemble ils ont réappris à être libre
comme il dit le fait qu'on sert grands
comptes et tout a changé aussi doit
changer
ouais ça joue sur le moral de la samp et
ça ça joue beaucoup et on se dit quand
même on est sorti quand on est quand
même sorti quoi fait que c'est comme
faire de quelque chose c'est comme
quelque chose
aujourd'hui leur luxe et d'avoir des
projets des vacances tout d'abord et
puis en juin ce sera le mariage
une page sportive avec est d'abord la
victoire de nathalie tauziat qui pour la
première fois gagné le tournoi de paris
son adversaire était de taille il
s'agissait de battre l'américaine serena
williams
handicapé par une douleur au genou la
championne a tenté de faire bonne figure
jusqu'au bout perdant 7 5 6 2 sébastien
nathalie tauziat et sa consécration cet
après midi la française victorieuse du
tournoi de paris en finale elle est
opposée à serena williams
une américaine en difficulté sur le
court c'est une surprise agréable pour
nathalie tauziat
elle remporte la première manche 7-5 et
le second set 6 2 wimbledon qui est
peut-être le summum de ma carrière je
crois que tous les tournois que j'ai pu
gagner mais ne représente pas sûr à 100
at il gagné chez sont nathalie tauziat
ou le porte drapeau du tennis féminin en
1999 la fédération française l'a choisi
pour un clip publicitaire aujourd'hui à
paris elle était la cible préférée des
spectateurs à ce titre en carrière à
l'as eu quelques difficultés à ses
débuts mais je trouve qu'elle finira
très bien est elle se bonifie en
vieillissant
nathalie tauziat à 32 ans désormais 5e
meilleure joueuse du monde son meilleur
classement
et pourtant cette année elle pourrait
bien mettre un terme à sa carrière
football avec la cenal de la vanne
deuxième coupe d'afrique des nations le
nigeria qui ces derniers jours ne
vivaient que dans l'attenté de cette
épreuve le nigeria est plus que déçu
puisqu'il a dû s'incliner devant le
cameroun après une séance de tirs au but
les deux équipes sont à égalité 2 à 2
finalement le cameroun l'emporté 4 tirs
au but à 3 souper le héros de bande
dessinée mondialement connue est
orphelin son créateur charles schulz est
décédé hier soir des suites d'un cancer
il était âgé de 77 ans il laisse
derrière lui une oeuvre pleine de charme
de poésie et d'humour
son dernier dessin dans un quotidien est
paru aujourd'hui aux états unis alors
que charles schulz avait annoncé qu'il
arrêtait la bande dessinée des peanuts
gérard belmas snoopy chant lebron linus
salies marcy lucide oiseaux ou stocks
toute la bande des pilotes est
désespérée leur papa américains pris la
tangente vers le paradis des
dessinateurs de bd
la maladie a eu raison de la joie de
l'île de charles schulz 77 ans qui
prenait plaisir quotidien aux états
d'âme de ces comédie humaine
18000 en un demi-siècle humour désabusé
voire cruel genre lewis carroll schulz
s'inspirait de ces rencontres pour sa
galerie de portraits charlie bonne
le perdant soucieux frustré incapable de
marquer un but de se faire obéir par son
chien snoopy rêveur philosophe au
fantasme récurrent s'identifier à la
salle mans de 14 18 le baron linus est
un albb pouces fiché en bouche est
complètement fichue s'en sont de doux ou
encore lucy une et râleuse qui sait tout
une emmerderait serait dit brasse
l'hebdomadaire charlie hebdo a choisi
son titre en hommage à charlie brawn gp
se souvient des débuts de peanuts en
france le succès n'a pas été vraiment
spontané
malheureusement en france il a fallu
énormément de temps avant que cet humour
universel puissent est apprécié par les
français parce qu'on prétendait que les
français n'étaient complètement
imperméable à l'humour de schultz
c'est à dire à l'humour très très
anglo-saxon et au non-sens dernier album
de charles schulz
clin d'oeil à la saint valentin 2010
ultime messages de tendresse à sa vraie
famille
la bd la plus célèbre du monde
cinéma avec la sortie mercredi prochain
de la plage marquant le retour sur les
écrans de leonardo dicaprio la star très
attendu depuis le triomphe mondial de
titanic s'est lancé à l'assaut de
l'europe ces derniers jours a clamé à
berlin aux côtés de virginie ledoyen
l'actrice française qui partage la fiche
de ce film de danny boyle et que j'ai le
plaisir de recevoir mais d'abord
l'évocation de ce film la recherche des
plaisirs et des sensations fortes la
quête obsessionnelle d'un paradis une
parabole sur la société d'aujourd'hui
nicole cornu langlois jean pierre
pasteur
un kilomètre béchard
j'ai passé américain
photo maël cependant km
dessiner ses ponts sera jamais
et c'est ainsi que leonardo le plus
célèbre naufragés de l'histoire du
cinéma
stimulé par nos deux françaises virginie
guilhaume se jette à l'eau et débarque
sur une île paradisiaque de la thaïlande
pour l' aventure de la plage présenté
dans l'hystérie collective au festival
de berlin
on peut descendre moi je dis qu'on fait
ce seuil on ne saute pas arrête de dire
n'importe quoi mais toi conte l'histoire
de deux descentes
c'est une idée de fond alors que deux
langues
tous les ingrédients sont réunis pour
créer l'événement comme en témoigne la
conférence de presse avec toute l'équipe
dont leonardo dicaprio qui évoque son
personnage il est à la recherche
d'expériences forte et aussi ce qui me
fascinait dans ce personnage
sans avoir la prétention de parler pour
ma génération c'est que je me sentais
très proche de cette quête de la sagesse
celle que l'on rêve d'atteindre
l'histoire est en tournée sous la
direction du sulfureux danny boyle
on se doute vite que le trio idyllique
va se déchirer les rivalités vont naître
la vie communautaire tourner au désastre
la jalousie c'est par les amis tels
vraiment je t'assure je sais pas de quoi
tu parles
tout le monde sait tout chacun se
construit soi même ce qu'on a envie de
ce dont on a envie ce qu'on aime et tout
ça et c'est pas parce qu'on est dans un
endroit sublime qu'on est forcément
heureux
telle pourrait être la morale de ce
conte exotiques dans lequel le paradis
devient descente aux enfers mais nos
trois acteurs eux sortent gagnants de
cette histoire de voir ce soir vous
arrivez tout juste de berlin beaucoup de
bruit de fureur autour de la sortie
événement de ce film comment vous vivez
vous ce tourbillon
c'est très très nouveau pour moi mon
temps c'est c'est assez surréaliste
c'est vrai que leonardo dicaprio suscite
une attente extraordinaire qui je
croyais justifiée parce que c'est un
très bon acteur mais en même temps c'est
très excitant
vous avez pas été un peu inspirés par ce
vertige je sais pas je sais pas si je me
rendrai compte mais non c'est vrai c'est
vrai qu'à une spirale même temps c'est
drôle
il ya un côté presque amusant alors on
va tout de suite en finir avec la
question leonardo dicaprio comment s'est
passé le tournage comment se passe la
rencontre au fond qu'est-ce qui vous a
touché ou louis murat en lui c'est
d'abord je crois un acteur extrêmement
brillant très généreux jeu c'est
difficile de parler de quelqu'un dont
tout le monde attend tant de choses mais
mais c'est un garçon qui se trouvait
très équilibré qui vit une chose qui
arrive à peu de gens et qui est très
bien entouré et je crois très équilibré
donc c'était un vrai plaisir de
travailler avec lui des défauts qui vous
touchent des défauts oui je crois qu'il
est il et il est naïf mais dans le bon
sens du terme je crois qu'il est encore
très innocent et que et que tout ce qui
se passe autour de vie finalement il en
rit il a beaucoup de dérision c'est
assez drôle alors quatre mois de
tournage en thaïlande
un tournage en plus en anglais j'imagine
que c'est une musique différente ça pas
été forcément un tournage idyllique
comme le semble montrer les images de la
plage c'était c'était dans un cadre
absolument paradisiaque
il y avait une énergie qui était qui
était assez fantastique avec des acteurs
qui venait du monde entier un metteur en
scène comme danny boy anglais léo darius
khondji guillaume c'était mais c'était
très fatiguant c'était assez éprouvant
mais puis jouer en anglais c'est pas non
c'est pas ma langue
enfin même si on sait que ce film va
vous ouvrir une carrière internationale
comme j'ai lu ici ou là au fond c'était
c'était à paris une aventure que vous
avez envie simplement de jouer que ça
sans plan de carrière
oui non puis quand on sait on ne pense
pas à ce genre de choses donc on ne fait
pas comme ça arrive on les prend avec
part avec philosophie mais avec joie
maintenant je sais pas ce que ça va
devenir mais j'espère simplement que le
film le film plaira à tous et vous avez
les pieds sur terre
on a le sentiment que vous répondez que
vous n'êtes pas prise par ce tourbillon
justement alors ce film est tiré d'un
livre américain qui a tout de suite été
un livre culte ou départ à ce que vous
avez l'impression que les générations
françaises et quelle génération vont se
retrouver dans ce ce récit un peu
initiatique ce voyage romantique qui va
tourner court
mais ce qui est fascinant dans le roman
d'alex garland des je crois dans la
plage dans le film c'est que justement
que ça ne s'adresse pas une culture
propre particulière c'est vraiment
l'image du monde aujourd'hui à savoir d
après quasiment plus de frontières les
autoroutes de l'information sont
gigantesques on communique avec qui ont
comme on veut et avec qui on veut et ce
film parle de ça c'est qu'aujourd'hui il
n'y a plus de frontières
et au final les jeunes gens sont à la
recherche des mêmes choses alors j'en
viens à vous parce que j'ai envie un peu
de parler de vous au delà du film
vous avez une carrière vous avez déjà
une stature déjà du métier je dirais il
ya un prix à payer pour vivre cette
passion à quel cinéma qui faisait déjà
propulsé assez loin au jeu je le vois
pas comme ça moi je le vois avec
beaucoup de bonheur j'ai toujours voulu
être actrice j'ai la chance de l'être
aujourd'hui je sais pas quel est le prix
à payer du travail mais c'est plutôt un
travail qui est qui est excitant et 10
me plaît mais une toute dernière
question rapidement j'ai aussi le
sentiment qui a pas d'étiquette qui a
pas de carcans coup-franc vous
multipliez les rôles les aventures elles
sont toutes différentes
c'est votre liberté c'est comme ça que
vous voulez jouer oui c'est ma liberté
puis je crois que c'est aussi sa
détractrice et d'aller vers des univers
différents des personnages des cultures
est en tout cas c'est comme ça que moi
j'envisage mon métier merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions et on vous
suivra
merci à vous c'est la fin de ce journal
je vous rappelle le principal titre de
cette édition tension kosovo de nouveaux
incidents à m
ça la force française en première ligne
deux soldats blessés les affrontements
entre communautés serbe et albanaise se
poursuivre
20h50 votre film danse avec les loups
avec kevin costner 23h50 les documents
du dimanche dans le monde de
l'aristocratie les clés du château
terroir 50 le dernier journal laurence
ostolaza demain 13h carole gaessler
rachid arhab amateurs vous retrouverez
claude sérillon j'en remercie de votre
attention excellente soirée sur france 2
votre soirée s'ouvre